des lits solidaire et qui roule une
vague de soutien qui se développe au
portugal face à la situation sanitaire
critique la population s'engager donne
de son temps à travers l'initiative kama
solidaria ouli solidaire en français
elle a pour but d'offrir de l'aide aux
professionnels de santé dans le besoin
les dons se multiplient et les
détenteurs de camping-cars ont ainsi
mise à disposition leurs caravanes qui
se sont également transformée en centre
de dos des produits d'hygiène ont
également été collectés comme son rival
et en movimiento cave ap il confond le
lit solidaire est un mouvement qui vise
à donner du temps et du confort aux
professionnels de la santé a déclaré
l'un des organisateurs du projet
comment nous avons un site web et si
j'ai un camping car ou une maison
je peux le mettre à la disposition des
professionnels de la santé
si je suis un professionnel de la santé
je peux dire j'ai besoin d'une maison et
d'un lit logement mais également apport
en énergie nourriture couvertures et
draps de lit pour les pompiers s'ajoute
à la liste des besoins urgents au
portugal une vague de solidarité qui ne
profitent pas qu'aux professionnels de
santé reconfirmer depuis le 15 janvier
les écoliers sont contraints de suivre
leurs cours en ligne des bénévoles
distribuent de nombreux ordinateurs
portables quelques milles ont été
récoltés en 48 heures l'initiative a
pris de l'ampleur depuis quinze jours on
s'amusait contracte campagne nous sommes
déjà en contact avec d'autres pays même
en dehors de l'europe pour pouvoir en
faire une chose plus universel et pour
que les gens se joignent à nous dans le
monde entier grâce aux réseaux sociaux
j'ai appris à connaître cette initiative
comme je n'avais pas de travail à ce
moment là il m'a semblé que comme nous
tous il fallait idée
une ces dames jouable selon les
dernières données le portugal a
enregistré plus de 13 mille deux cents
décès dont près de la moitié depuis le
début de l'année 2021
si les chiffres ont tendance à baisser
les hôpitaux n'en reste pas moins
surchargé